i'm about to call
this special meeting of long-range
capital planning and utilization
committee to order i would remind all of
the members
of the committee that
it is going out live
live streamed
so that if you have a comment question
please make sure that you press the
button on the microphone in front of you
and the red light is showing so that
those who are listening in
can
hear what we are saying as well as
watching us
um
look around i do declare that there is a
quorum present
and so for the special meeting we are
only taking up new business
and the new business is under rsa for
cohen 30-b approval of state agency
leases exceeding five years
lrcp
22-019 department of administrative
services authorization to enter into a
20-year lease agreement with 81 hall
street llc for approximately 106
400 square feet of usable office space
considering consisting of the entire
entire south building portion of a
certain office building located at one
granite place concord new hampshire
together with the land underlying said
south building and related parking areas
and driveways at a fixed annual base
rent of one million one hundred and
seventy nine thousand four hundred
dollars payable and equal monthly
installments effective for the period of
july first
2022 through june 30th 2042 subject to
the conditions as specified in the
request
dated june 21st dash
uh june 21st 2022
i would ask the commissioner to come
forward and explain
the process and where we are on this
lease
hi
sorry uh hi i'm charlie arlinghaus i'm
the commissioner of administrative
services and with me is uh jordan island
who's our real property manager um uh
jared will be the lawyer in the room
today um so that i don't say anything
that gets me in trouble
um
so people know i think that this is
about the parking garage
um it doesn't look like it's about the
parking garage but it is about the
parking garage um there's a there's a
plan the legislature has uh long
eyed the spot of the
savings bank building the
that it currently houses the department
of justice
since we bought it in 1993 as a
potential parking garage to replace the
one on store street that is in less than
ideal condition
although perfectly safe if you happen to
be parking in it i just want to
emphasize that
but
has a very short life ahead of it it's
well past its useful life and
um
we pick up the concrete that falls a lot
so to do so to tear down the department
of justice building which is what i'm
going to call it
you would have to move them out of it
or else tear down very carefully
and um
to move them out of it you have to put
them somewhere um and they wouldn't
quite naturally like to all go in the
same place which is a very difficult
thing to do there are very few spots
in concord where you can fit
roughly 50 000 square feet of people
people offices etc in office space the
only options realistically are
converting retail space
or this particular space that is the old
lincoln financial building or chubb life
if people remember it as that the old
building off rumford street
in concord up toward the prison
so we negotiated at least
and the legislature was actively
involved in negotiating the the least
terms of it were basically agreed to by
the
chief operating officer of the
legislature more than anyone else
um and we uh
and we said okay
um that's a good idea terry um which is
what i think most people do when they
talk to terry um and uh and so this is
the least what you have before you are
the terms it is a 20-year lease and
there's a within the lease there's an
option to buy there are two towers on
that site right two buildings
um each um
um
each roughly the same size they're both
about a hundred thousand square feet
they were built about ten years apart
the one currently houses in about half
of it the administrative office of the
courts and then a couple of uh sort of
non-public entities
in that the state has an option the
judicial branch if you will so has an
option to buy that
that building which we may or may not
exercise someday i don't predict what
courts will do
or want to do
and then we would naturally have an
option on this i think i think there's a
school of thought that thinks that we
would buy this building
and the lease will specify that that's
about 15 million dollars which is
significantly less than the cost of
building a hundred thousand square feet
probably a third of the cost of building
a hundred thousand square feet
um but in the meantime
we have a 20-year lease
and it's uh it's 11 triple net lease but
the document before you is a great
summary of all the lease provisions
um
and in terms of having a
a reasonable office space for the
department of justice that suits them
and may in addition um suit some other
agencies we have you know significant
needs
um
this is a it's actually a fairly decent
building and it um has parking which is
i have to answer any questions i don't
want to go into way too much detail on
the lease but i'm happy to go into any
detail
mr chairman
representative clute here hey thank you
so i assume you you talk with the
department of justice and they think
that this uh
building would be adequate to their
needs for the foreseeable future they
think it is quite suitable they've been
over a couple times on a tour and yes
they do i think they think it's um
significantly more suitable to their
needs than their current space
okay thank you mr chairman thank you
commissioner uh commissioner i i know we
have like a an mou
in front of us at the moment
when do you
anticipate having the lease son and two
governor and council because if we come
in here in july and it's september or
october before you have a lease ready
several of us are going to be
miffed shall i say the the deadline for
the august meeting is um july 27th and
we will make we will meet that deadline
right
yeah
representative edwards uh thank you mr
chair uh good morning mr arlinghaus
i think i heard you say that the doj's
need was about 50 000 square feet the
building's about a hundred thousand
square feet so that opens up some
questions on the extra fifty thousand
square feet um bureaucracies have a way
of expanding to fill all available space
it's something i've learned in
corporations too
um and i'd like to know what we're going
to do to ensure that we don't find
ourselves expanding to 100 000
need when the need is 50.
specifically if you want to include this
in your answer um
are there any other target departments
that we can move
freeing up another building that we
could
uh close out somehow
are we looking at any other departmental
moves
um we it's actually a great question and
i agree with you one of the things that
keeps um
state entities from expanding into
available space
is the requirement that they that they
pay for the space so the space isn't
free there are there are charges in the
budget process that are transfers that
are rent-like charges we occasionally
call them rent even though they're not
rent or the their allocated portion of
the costs of actually of karen's
department
um and so uh that sort of limits you i
mean there are people who would like to
who you know we have discussions with
and they're like oh we'd like to you
know we'd like to lease about 10 000
square feet and the first question is
always how much is in your budget and um
uh people who are newish will say oh
does that matter and the answer is
typically yes yes it does
um so that will prevent that from
happening i think that that our current
plan is to identify some areas where
there's significant
um uh renovation or maintenance need in
in in buildings the the state has a
number of buildings that are relatively
um mediocre
or that's not a good that's not a good
way of putting it that are in need of a
great deal of work either asbestos
remediation or or various other issues
um we have a lot of hvac issues right
now for example
and one of the things that is an
obstacle to fixing that space routinely
is um the availability of swing space
i'm going to use as a as a
as a silly but directly
relevant to me example
um we have a capital project that that
dates from actually the 2019 capital
budget um but was suspended during the
pandemic because it's not critical it
wasn't critical
um but which is a significant um
overhaul of the state house annex
building
the building built in 1939 and and which
hasn't had significant work and has
riddled with asbestos and bad wiring and
and things like that
and we're doing a lot of work and you
know the architects will say to you well
you know what we could probably do this
if you could move about half the people
out of the building and i said what if
we could move out like 20 people at a
time instead of 200 at a time
and they'd look at you appalled and then
we do that one of the things we are
going to use some of the space for
because it is
when lincoln financial left they left
everything behind including all the
furniture which is unusual for us and as
a remarkable
asset to us is use it for for some of
that to take uh portions of people out
of buildings that we're renovating the
annex is a great example and put them in
there and then move them back
and so we are uh we're doing a lot of
space planning along those lines
karen and i for example met recently on
this and some of it is going to be
related to in terms of capital budget
and a couple of arpa projects
what are we fixing and that'll tell us
who's going to move but at the end of
the day
as a result of this
no agency will have more square footage
than they have today
with with the one exception being doj
and if you've if you've been inside doj
you can see why that might be the case
and in addition there are more we have
more lawyers than we used to
follow up
so what i heard you say though is that
long term we're expecting we're going to
have an ongoing surplus of 50 000 square
feet
and that although that may be used in
the interim
for some some some flipping of spaces to
renovate other spaces long term it's
still 50 000 square feet extra
uh long term the state will have 50 000
square feet um yes but i think one of
the things we would do so we currently
rent something like 200 and
250 000 square feet of office space
around congress all right and um
and one of the things that we would do
is is look to rent less if we're running
a larger space we would look if there
are entities that can move in there
there are people who are at the end of a
useful
useful lease life and and sometimes they
either want to leave or have to leave
and so we would look at doing that
the amount of lease space i would expect
the state to have over the next let's
just say decade
is probably not going to
change dramatically would there be ups
and downs within that number yeah
probably
but
not
not dramatic ups and downs
you know 10 or 20 this way or that way
and i i think that
one of the things that we want to try to
do
is you know ideally we would you know
the plan when we started renovating the
state office park south
the the gallon office park the old
hospital campus was to try to move
people out of rented space and they'd
actually been a you know it's the theory
when they built a state house
expansion when they built the annex et
cetera
and we've done some of that you know if
you look at the old master plan we
renovate this building move them out of
the leaf space into into state space and
i think we'll get there but i don't
think the state's ever really going to
have
um uh quite as much borrowing a
significant
um thank you and and to follow on um we
heard
earlier this
last month i guess it was now at least
one agency is looking at buying another
building in concord to move out of
a building or a gallon that is
less than desirable it needs a lot of
work um those are the types of things
that i'm sure that the commissioner or
his successors will be looking at
not trying to get rid of you charlie but
i was gonna say
let's not talk about successes i would
make this request
um you have a representative who is on
this committee um
very ably on this committee i would
expect that at
the meetings of long-range
utilization committee
that
items such as
what's going to be going in there what's
coming out of that building as we go
forward would be presented to this
committee
and its new
construction after the next election and
i think that that's fair it gives the
legislature some oversight on what's
going on without being overly burdensome
to
the
department
you know i happily can commit to that we
will we will uh uh tell you what's going
on as as often as you would like and
whenever you would like and um
we can do it without without almost any
notice and so you know karen's going to
be here anyway and she's going to know
what's going on
senator burnsville
thank you mr chair
um
commissioner do you have any idea how is
there a cost to
renovating or retrofitting this
particular area for doj
um and how much is it if so how much is
it the the legislature in the in the in
the bill that the legislature passed and
which i think was 1661 but i don't don't
homie to that um
the okay and it is in the packet it was
um
there's set aside there's uh about a
million dollars for for quote-unquote
moving costs and i don't want people to
think that's putting people in a van
that involves a lot of the i.t
infrastructure and things
um and about uh three and a half i think
it's 3.75 million for um for
retrofitting the space
the
biggest
cause of that is uh
need for additional offices
the
you know many state agencies have very
have a very small number of offices
but
doj sort of is disproportionately
officed if you will because they're
lawyers
um thank you mr chairman commissioner
nice to see you
the um two two uh quick questions i
believe one last my last visit to doj is
uh well they need a lot of office space
i i was crowded by boxes everywhere i
went with files and records
so i'm hoping that's accounted and i'm
sure it is so you don't need the answer
my second is you'd made mention that if
we were to start from scratch and owned
our own land a hundred thousand dollars
square foot we couldn't do it for this
so to speak general number what it cost
for square foot this year now to put up
a building for the state we we had been
using as a rule of thumb something like
four hundred dollars a square foot um
and i think that's uh based on what's
what we're seeing with construction
costs right now i think that's probably
low and it's probably more like 500 now
okay um i mean if i were for example you
just put it this way if we went to the
uh capital budget with an item to build
a hundred thousand square foot building
um we would we would probably ask them
uh at an initial estimate for 50.
thank you
thank you mr chairman
any further questions from members of
the committee
what is the pleasure of the committee
then
mr chair
i move
to approve
lrcp 22-019
representative mills moves approval
senator d'alessandro seconds the motion
is there any further discussion on this
item
say none all those in favor of the
motion to approve item
22-019 signify by saying aye aye opposed
nay the eyes have it and the
motion
thank you thank you mr chairman and
thank i want to thank the members of the
committee for um rousting themselves and
driving to concord on a on a
quote-unquote emergency basis i really
appreciate it uh thank you
there is no other business this was the
only business we were going to take up
the next meeting of uh
long-range capital planning and
utilization committee is scheduled for
monday september 19 2022
until that time the committee stands
adjourned
it took far five minutes longer than i
thought
you